let's talk about it conor mcgregor out
here [ __ ] people up again
do you think conor mcgregor has ct and i
mean that i asked daddy i had that exact
thought what do you think either he's
just completely falling apart because
the thing that he put his self-worth on
even he has everything else that's been
taken
or it's legit cte
so let's let's go off of number one like
it's just ego right yeah i think that
yeah when you build yourself up and your
entire adult life you think of yourself
as like
the most
terrifying human being on the planet yes
like you can [ __ ] up anybody even though
he can't [ __ ] up the guys at the higher
weight classes you know regular
pedestrians you [ __ ] them up right a
dj yeah i'm not afraid of dj's his
self-worth is i kick people's ass yeah
so now once you stop believing yourself
that you can kick people's asses i think
you're incredibly sensitive yeah to any
provocation from a pedestrian yes right
from a civilian yeah right so
you have you have a situation where like
um
yeah you ever have somebody like
you ever somebody be condescending to
you maybe they think that you're like
broke or they think you're like stupid
or something like that i'm insecure so
that drives me [ __ ] nuts and then i
get real pissed right and then if they
like laugh at you in like a weird way
yeah yeah yeah you're like hate you
forever exactly because you're dealing
with that insecurity right so conor
never had that insecurity and now he has
the insecurity himself which is maybe i
can't [ __ ] people up like i used to yeah
and then if a dj some italian dj at that
any italian really yeah
anything
yeah that's what i mean
any italian or dj could get [ __ ] up
together this guy's asking for an
italian dj does something he probably
isn't even to you it's maybe to his wife
maybe conor says hey we should go to the
next spot and then he goes yeah yeah
sure we'll go to the next spot or
something like that and maybe he's
talking to his wife maybe it's an inside
joke about his wife and they both don't
like going after hours places so he's
winking at his wife sure we'll go to the
next spot nothing to do with conor but
connor's so sensitive that [ __ ]
don't respect him no more yeah did
immediately or you getting punched in
the mouth or that dj was italian and
started playing bongos on her titties
and [ __ ] like that oh do they do that i
mean italians that's how they talk
al i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
now i seriously i wanted to yes and you
and i want to improv yes i have to bring
this to a screeching halt this is why
i'm not good at improv yeah cuomo is
very good dumb [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
that's italian american that's different
oh yeah yeah in america i don't know
different people my bad different group
of people basically what happened is in
around 14
this is true all the straight people in
italy left yeah oh really they moved to
new york yeah all the straight people in
italy moved there's only 40 of them on
the boat though there was only four of
them on the boat there's a lot of gays
and uh the rest of them stayed there and
then they started doing fashion things
and they started uh caring about if the
tomatoes were ripe and that's just what
they've been doing really for the last
500 years maybe 550 years got it easily
confusing situation not your fault at
all so straight italians here super
straight yeah
bongos titties yeah
gays that are still in italy
doing their thing gotcha so that's why
we see these yeah slip-on shoes yeah
slip-on shoes really tiny little those
little ferrari shoes yeah just wear
socks what are you doing watching yeah
why ferrari shoes you're not going to be
fast
yeah i see the fastest man on the plane
is actually a tally no oh yeah it's true
american
the fast part is american you didn't get
just me from your mom and the ferrari
shoes probably huh and the ferrari shoes
and the frogs you wore the frogs
but it's like when you see a little kid
in like lightning mcqueen shoes
how are they not good at marathons all
they do is carbo load all day every day
yeah all you're eating is pasta and
you're not good at marathons
with the ferrari shoes i mean you have
to give it up for the metabolism oh yeah
dude you have to give it up for the
metabolism like they eat the food that
you shouldn't eat like
and live mad long the number one diet in
america is just don't eat like an
italian
and they're still skinnier yes you've
got to give it up 100 what do you think
that is is the food better i think i
think they talk with their hands it's
just so much more exercise so fast yeah
their mouth is the ferrari and also just
sucking [ __ ] okay i think a lot of the
guys are just busy sucking coconuts
the wife because the wife is like i have
to go to the farmer's market get the new
cabbage and then the husband's like i'll
suck the [ __ ]
get the alfredo yes we get the sauce
you get the pasta i make the sauce
so yeah so we figured out italy and why
they're so skinny yeah um
yo about conor though you fight fighting
is even more heightened like you're
saying yeah i think any time like
imagine all of a sudden you just weren't
funny anymore let's knock on woods
that's even [ __ ] up yes yes yes you're
going to spiral
are you superstitious
i think for a good like seven years yeah
you'd be killing for two months and it
should be like oh [ __ ] i got this i got
this figured out this is exactly how i'm
gonna do my special and then you'd hit a
rut and then for a month
it would just get worse actively oh god
and usually afterward you'd grow more
but it's like a [ __ ] valley to get to
the people yeah for me like that was
always the the growth process it was
like and i at first i didn't realize it
but it was like do better do better do
better start doing worse
and then all of a sudden there was like
that was like uh the next growth stage
and eventually when i started doing
worse i was like oh okay good i'm about
to grow yeah something's going to happen
i'm going to be funnier i'm going to
understand the game more but like before
i understood that oh it's [ __ ] brutal
i mean i think there were times where i
was like on the phone with i can
remember distinctly walking on an aster
place by the barber shop and just call
an akash bike bro
i think i lost it
i think i lost it he's like what are you
talking about
funny man
i used to be funny
[Laughter]
but yeah i remember that and i remember
i did a show that night oh my god
then we'll get off this but i did a show
that night and i was so angry and so
depressed that i actually had like a
breakthrough
like i was so angry so depressing it was
a horrible show i was in the [ __ ]
east village there was like eight people
there and for some reason like i wasn't
trying to do the jokes i i i i couldn't
be anything but what i felt yeah and the
audience like really resonated with it
and then just started laughing and all
of a sudden like the jokes had new light
yeah
and one of those moments where i
realized like i need to be connected to
the material i need to like feel
something about it and i think if i
didn't have that show i would have um
quit comedy
he wouldn't be making a living a
comedian which means none of us
i also think the audience that night
knew you needed it
your memory is like yeah i connected
like what you actually said was like if
you guys were alive i'm gonna kill
myself yeah it was like the joker moment
guys are all gonna die yeah yeah he's
like oh yeah this guy's running
but in those times you're [ __ ] lost
man and conor's lost he was and we
thought the best in the world then it
just now it's all gone it feels like
we're all just kind of looking at him
like he kicked my ass but like because
think about all the interactions
recently right and i'm not talking about
when he punched the old guy in the bar
because old guys in bars can be dicks
like that guy he could have yeah that
guy deserved 100 percent because he
could be some [ __ ] old bar fly he's
already drunk and he thinks since he's
old nobody's going to hit him you know
how like like old old guys
talk like young women
you know what i mean like they say [ __ ]
like there's no repercussions yeah yeah
yeah son i would have remember larry
merchant was talking [ __ ] to floyd yeah
yeah all of us were looking at larry
merchant like yeah there's no way
floyd's doing [ __ ]
didn't you say if i was younger i'd have
kicked your ass oh you wouldn't this is
the best boxer ever larry you were larry
you couldn't throw punches nothing as a
man you hit 70 you turned to a woman
exactly socially
yeah 100 percent it is a freedom yeah
like oh i can't wait i'm talking to the
italian right now no one gives a [ __ ]
no it's are you too old
it's happening with holding the infinite
breaking news is over sorry
excuse me so i know it's kind of gay to
sit how i sit but the way that dove
points his toe down
oh he's wearing italian shoes don't do
that right like i feel like this with my
foot up because i'm ready to [ __ ] you
know i'm ready to go like you're ready
to be straight yeah
i'm so ready to be straight you're
trying to roll them into it
like my father walks in the room like yo
what are y'all doing like i'm so ready
to be straight right but gov is like a
goddamn ballerina dude yeah yeah what is
that what is that like
like like
you were really good at that by the way
you were switching them legs
dancers dance teachers that
was son of a dance dj i thought i wasn't
gonna be on a dance you could cut son of
a dancer and just say dancer you just
you're a dancer no
he's a son of a dancer dog yo i'm a son
of a dancer bro i'm sort of a dance
teacher that's the name of the
three-time u.s ballroom dance champion
yeah i've never heard him
okay tell us what happened i want to
read it and i don't want to do it okay
i'll do oh god dude okay
it's like having a girlfriend you don't
want to [ __ ] i know right um
okay uh the girl says uh i think he had
the psychotic episode or something
uh then doug goes uh maybe because he
doesn't know what to do uh now that his
career is over israel is great we were
in this place did he say that yeah
we were in a circle talking deciding
what to do he wanted to go somewhere
with the music oh she was there
sam said they were going home
some said they were staying francesco
said okay let's stay then and yeah he
just turned his head slowly and yeah and
through punch
open eyes emoji and then his friends and
guards had to hold them down because he
want to keep beating francesco so i
don't think it's something pre-meditated
or russia well respond you should
respond to her didn't you no please wait
why not just respond he discussed this
with you before didn't you just say that
he was like
you just gave that example yeah tmz dove
got got on the scoop right before yeah
wait so so she just agreed with
everything we said i just said why are
italian men so gay okay i swear to god
no no please i did say that
it's what it is i just want to know i
think it's an important thing to know
yeah you actually wrote that yeah of
course i wrote it well maybe we'll get
an answer she's italian right we're
listening people
i've never said yeah
they're sweet why do you think it's
gonna be sweet
okay um but yeah i think that's what it
is man because if you look at the other
uh interaction they had that altercation
with mgk and it was the same kind of
thing yeah right everybody was alleging
he asked for a pick and the mgk was like
nah and it was like yo you think you
could disrespect me yeah uh he should
have [ __ ] them to care for that yeah
that is wow
all anybody's doing is taking pictures
have you ever turned out a picture in
your life from someone nah that's what i
mean like you're like yeah i'm just i
will
i turn that on
for a picture i'm turning that [ __ ] down
we're making news
i want to call her to punch an amish guy
he's like oh cause they can't take
pictures yes he can't use technology at
all he's gonna fight him he's getting
pissed
you